twice a week this group of young people
meets up for soccer training their
apprentices in Liberia's capital
Monrovia their firm encourages them to
play soccer because it fosters team
spirit meeting here was nearly
impossible during the Ebola epidemic
instead this team raised awareness about
how to stop the disease from spreading
for us it was challenging do but the
soccer players the young people you CN
came together they were mobilized by the
kick for the future project along with
the management team we went out in the
community is telling people a body
preventive metals how to wash your hands
a for some food that you shouldn't eat
cook your food properly ever all close
contact even now reminders of Ebola
everywhere in Monrovia announcements
warn of the dangers of the disease and
educate people on how to avoid it
dispensers filled with chlorinated water
have been placed outside many public
buildings it's a measure that encourages
people to wash their hands outside
restaurants staff check people for signs
of a fever an early sign of Ebola but
the virus no longer defines people's
lives here nighttime curfews earth thing
of the past schools have reopened small
businesses have opened up again
Liberia's economy is slowly getting back
in gear what I haven't no customers but
I'll Islam Ebola she needs a customer
get cut around one more time for Twitter
a bullet also fitted cap before why more
people of the airfryer come for a
country to be declared ebola-free there
have to be no new cases reported for 42
days that's twice as long as a maximum
incubation time and it's been even
longer since Liberia's last case showed
up but many people are still worried
that the disease could break out again
and they're often scared of people from
neighboring Guinea and Sierra Leone
where the epidemic still rages
every week without a new case of Ebola
is a step forward on the road to
normalcy in Liberia people are going
back to school or to work or visiting
friends like they used to Ebola is no
longer the only topic and conversation
but Sofia remains the canisters was
disinfectant at every corner testified
for that